he's all quite simply our favorite to
talk to when it it comes to hoops he's
one of the best in the business no
matter the sport the senior nba writer
for espn and the host of brian windhorst
and the hoop collective podcast joining
me here on the mercedes-benz vans phone
line is brian windhorst how are you
brian
i'm good rich how are you i'm hanging in
there hanging in there so uh let's just
jump right into it
the los angeles lakers have been
eliminated from playoff contention not
even the play in tournament we are
as the crow flies literally three three
blocks away from the lakers
facility here in el segundo california
what do you think is happening in that
building
today
boy there's probably a whole lot of
white boards and there's probably a
whole lot of spreadsheets
but if i were rob palinka and jeannie
buss i would have pulled out my 2020
championship ring and just looked at it
and admired it
because that's what you're hanging on to
right now because
i just don't see a short-term way
forward for them
even if and the one thing that's always
sustained the lakers although they've
had dry spells is that
there's always been a player
who said i want to be a laker
even if that were to happen you know
last year
who said that i don't even think they
functionally functionally could get a
player like that right now so
i just think they're probably going to
have to take their medicine and spin
their wheels for a year
i don't see another way to do it
well but number six doesn't have a you
know years to spare right i know
i know that
so to me
the big thing is how was lebron going to
approach
this summer
so he has an option
stupid lakers are going to offer it i
mean i shouldn't maybe make any
assumptions but
on august 4th the lakers are a lumped
off him
a contact extension he has one year left
he's obviously still playing great
basketball
he's the years in them i don't know if
he's got four more years but he's got a
couple more years i would think at least
it would make sense that the lakers
would want to extend his contract
living in los angeles he loves being
elite he has to hate the predicament the
team is in
so does he extend his contract rich does
he put a vote of confidence in the team
that they'll you know get it corrected
does he chase the kareem record next
year
see if they can put together a team that
could maybe get into the
back of the playoffs i mean
right now they've got 31 wins rich i
don't know if they're going to give
another win let's just give them one
more win that means they're going to be
a 50 loss team
if they win
12 more games next year like everybody's
like well a.d has been hurt
when a.d westbrook and lebron played
together they played in 21 games
together they were 11 and 10. you know
if they were eight and three i could see
well you know if they're healthy that
they were 11 and 10 they were average
and you know so but let's just say
let's just give them 13 more wins next
year i mean that's a gift to me but
let's just give it to them let's say
next year they win 44 45 games
that's a play in position right now if
you had 45 wins this season in the west
you're in the play-in
so
i i i
don't know
you know in the past
would leave a situation like this he
left cleveland when they were in this
predicament the first time he left miami
when they were in a better position
predicament
in 2014 then left cleveland when they
were in this predicament in 2018.
normally this is what the clock would
strike and the hourglass would go up and
he would move but i don't think he wants
to so we'll see i guess let's just put a
fine point on it like
is there no way out i mean what give me
give me like
i know there's white boards and
everything like that but you know
jenny you know jeannie's sitting there
and polinka sitting there the rambay
are all sitting there um
they're you know lebron doesn't have
ideas to try and forward here i mean
there's there's just no
way out of this thing is what you seem
to be saying right here yeah and that's
why the westbrook trade is so penal it's
it doesn't just hurt because it didn't
work
it hurts rich
because it it kind of locked them into
this they don't have maneuverability now
so lebron's first year in la
they missed the playoffs the signings
that they had didn't work the team
wasn't a good mix
but they had young players at the time
they had drastics you know they walked
away from his first year in l.a they
ended up with the number four pick and
um brandon ingram and they turned that
into anthony davis
and they had cap space they don't have
any of that now they don't have young
players to trade they don't have draft
picks really to trade at any time they
don't have draft picks to use
um and westbrook's value is is negative
they they use enough there's no market
for him
so i i really think that their move is
is to spin the wheels and you know eat
the sandwich so to speak and
um hope that you can improve what you've
got so you can be competitive and then
try again in 23 24. i mean i
i hate to say it but i just don't see
another way
so is vogel definitely out is frank
vogel definitely out that's the one
i guess
for sure
i think that's going to happen um
but i i don't think that's i i don't
think frank put his best foot forward
this year
but i don't think that there's a coach
that's going to be able to change the
limitations that westbrook has at this
point in his career playing alongside
those two guys
so who would take the job i mean it's
still the lakers right so
what do you think and it's still lebron
playing at an mvp level you know so
what do you think about that well i'll
tell you one thing i wonder how much
they're going to pay
because
the reason that they have frank bogle
who won him a championship again he'll
walk away and hold the ring
but the reason that they have frank
vogel and not tyron lou is because they
didn't want to meet the price
so if they're going to go out and try to
hire the best coach on the market
whoever that may be and there's some
coaches out there
who may be pretty high profile who may
be out of their jobs
i mean are they going to pay you know
when they went to extend frank vogel
they gave him one year
um you know are
are they going to hire a coach that they
believe
it can make a difference when i'm not
sure the coach can make a difference in
the short term so that's the first
question i had is
you know are they going to are they
going to
you know make sure that every candidate
is interested in them because you know
last time around monty williams and ty
lue said no for a reason
so i mean uh i i guess we got to hear
from them if they make a coaching change
to hear about that brian windhorst here
on the rich eisen show from the
worldwide leader in sports so who else
it might be um on the hot seat right now
across the nba as we're heading into the
final
regular season weekend who else yeah
well i mean there's certain guys where
we're expecting changes like we're
expecting alvin gentry who's in the
interim coach to to be let go in
sacramento and there to be a change
there
but you know the juice that you're
looking for is where are there coaches
who made maybe a surprise change so you
know i think there are people who are
watching the utah jazz very closely uh
they've had a disappointing season if
they have a disappointing playoffs
there's a possibility of a change there
it just depends it'll depend on how the
season plays out and i think doc rivers
is under a measure of pressure
with the 76ers um
daryl mori even though they have a good
working relationship daryl mori did not
hire him
um
you know he is under pressure to deliver
with uh james harden
if they have an early out in the
postseason um and you know frankly
they've been struggling in late game
situations which has been a a achilles
heel for doc in his career i would watch
those two situations brian windhorst
here on the the rich eisen show what
about uh zion are we gonna see him
what's the scoop with him now that we
know who's essentially in the uh playing
tournament out west what do you think
about well
we know that zion wants to play rich
because a couple of weeks ago he wasn't
happy with how fast he was being cleared
and he posts a video
uh and the next day he got cleared to do
some more work and then yesterday
for the second time in three years
his stepfather who essentially is the
lead voice in his um in his in his
decision making
gave his second interview in three years
and in the interview in my view the
purpose was to tell people zion wants to
play
and so that was sort of
round two in applying public pressure to
the organization to play zion but this
is a guy
who as far as i know hasn't even had a
full contact practice
in almost a year
and you know the idea that they are
going to be able to take him through the
ramp up stages you know if he was just
out for a month and he'd been playing
during the season you know there's a
little bit more of a path but you're
going to have to take him through
numerous stages to make sure he's not
going to reinjure that foot so i'm not
going to sit here and say 100 percent no
because
i think the pressure's gonna still come
but the play-in tournament is less than
a week away
he's not playing in that and i don't
even know if the pelicans are winning
two games to get out of the play-in
tournament much less extending into the
postseason so
i don't see it but what's whether he
plays or not is not as important as the
actions being take being taken to apply
pressure to the pelicans that speaks
more to me than anything else so then
what is it saying to you when it's
speaking to you
brian it says to me that zion and the
team are not on the same page about his
recovery despite the fact that he's had
setback after setback after setback that
is pretty much wrecked this season for
him
so then why does he want to play
what's the point
well he wants to play because he thinks
he's healthy
but he said the last time he talked to
the media was in september and he said
i'll see you on opening
that was night months ago
what he thinks and uh what's reality
seem to be two different things
brian windhorst here on the program what
about ben simmons out for the playing
tournament nets win two they get in
um and man nets versus whoever finishes
up number one uh if that is in fact the
way it would go would be quite lit as
the kids say
um
is what's what is what is the scoop with
ben simmons
right yeah so the nets just had
probably their best day in weeks
because they woke up yesterday in 10th
place
and they won on uh
last night
and everybody else in the play and
tournament lost and that changed their
entire situation so now they're in
eighth
and if they
win the next two games they're gonna be
in seventh with full control of their
destiny
and being in seven changes everything
that gives them a chance to have a much
cleaner path
and i'll tell you the miami heat
i could see them
um sending um trays of of fruit
and offering um wonderful
post-game spreads
and post-season vacations um if they win
that game friday against the cavs
because if they win friday against the
cavs
i think miami is going to avoid him in
the first round so having said all that
you asked me about ben simmons yes
internally the team is saying
we can still bring him back we can get
him through a process
uh and play him and they believe that
they would play him despite him never
putting on a nets uniform
they are saying we can bring him back in
a playoff series
i think it would probably have to they'd
have to go
at least past the first round for that
to be realistic because like with zion
he hadn't played in like 340 days
so he can't just like say okay
you're cleared to play let's head out
let's do a stretching routine and get
out on the court they're going to have
to put him through
multiple contact practices so that they
see how his back reacts they can't risk
it otherwise it's not
prudent you know to do that and the
problem is the g league is done he can't
go there
and the team isn't going to be
practicing that much so
i'm not ruling it out but i think it's
probably going to take the nets to get
on up to pull at least one quote-unquote
upset to get deeper in to give him the
time to do it what about curry's ankle
steph curry's ankle in time for the
playoffs what are you hearing about
so to me like to me the west conference
playoffs is
jaws knee and curry's ankle
and both memphis and and golden state
are saying the same thing
don't worry about all these inactives
don't worry that they're not practicing
everything's going to be okay for the
playoffs wink wink we're gonna be fine
it's not my knee it's not my ankle maybe
that's true
maybe jaw will come springing out of the
tunnel for the opening round of the
playoffs maybe steph will be running
around like everything is fine um you
know
by the second round which is when
they're gonna really need him but if i
said i wasn't worried i'd be i wouldn't
be telling you the truth i think those
two factors are huge and another reason
why if you're the sons
you're you know you're feeling okay
about your situation especially if you
can avoid injury yourself yeah i mean um
they're sitting there atop the atop the
west and just kind of like uh
getting ready for for the big crucible
starting in a couple weeks for them um
before i let you go brian windhorst your
thoughts on the mvp conversation going
into the final weekend what do you think
yeah
i've got uh embiid right now on my top
line
um
i recognized you know yokita voted for
him last year and if he wins again it'll
be
honorable um at espn we did a straw poll
that published last week tim bontemps
from our staff where he actually
told the voters and it's important to
know rich
there's only 100 voters it's kind of
like the senate
so if you convince
10 people to twitch to switch their vote
that's it's not like a heisman the
heisman or something like you know
there's over a thousand heisman voters
um
it's not like that so um it's very hard
to just say oh yeah so-and-so is going
to win
a year ago bon thames did this poll um
two weeks before the end of the season
and declared it over he said jokic has
got it no one's catching him
the poll showed that jokic
was in the lead
62 first place votes to i believe 19 for
mb the second and giannis was a distant
third
um and that that poll to me is solid
gold you know who else thinks so las
vegas because the odds um jokic went
into less than even money after that
came out so yokish is showing no signs
of slowing down he keeps putting up
great games um i am super impressed with
him beat at both ends of the court and
uh have had him in as my mvp for two
three months now and i'm i'm leaning
towards going that way huh and uh jokic
is not gonna get any
uh the cavalry's not coming in the
playoffs for the nuggets you don't think
from the injury
i mean
i'll tell you one thing uh murray and
porter are doing more
than and simmons and zion are so
but but michael porter jr had a setback
in his recovery the nuggets haven't
exactly explained what it is but
um
i he was closer than murray and then he
had a setback
so
i suppose again if if they get far in
the playoffs it's more likely but right
now neither are close
brian you're the man i just again love
our chats you make me smarter you get me
excited about uh you know the
association and um and i you know
although laker fans hearing what you
have to say probably are crying in their
soup a little bit more today they know
they already
know take care brian thanks for the call
thanks guys that's brian winoor senior
nba writer brian windhorst and the hoop
collective podcast in the old espn pod
center at windhorst espn on twitter i
follow him you should too hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here